[Music]
most of us don't spend much time
thinking about the grid the dizzyingly
huge system of cables transformers and
outlets that reliably powers our lives
it's an easily ignored change-resistant
part of the modern world and that's the
way we like it
but as we move towards less planet
melting ways of producing electricity
the grid is going to have to evolve too
we're seeing so many countries and
governments announcing high targets when
it comes to decarbonization and being
climate neutral
but this is just one side of the coin
it's not enough to simply generate green
energy we also need to make sure that
this transmitted and distributed to the
end consumers
the grid of today just isn't equipped
for renewables
so a new kind of grid is starting to
take shape
the super grid
the idea behind a super grid is
basically a grid that connects nations
not just different parts of a country
and the goal is to try and maximize the
use of renewables wherever they are
generating electricity
it's an ambitious idea and one that
could be necessary to avoid the worst
case scenarios of climate change
but actually building it is a tough
proposition
i have to say politics is the most
difficult thing we are still trying to
struggle each other competing each other
a super grid seems like a super good
idea the question is will it ever become
a reality
since the earliest days of harnessing
electricity getting power where it needs
to go has been at least as big a
challenge as making it in the first
place
and we're talking about the earliest
days since thomas edison's first
electric grid in downtown manhattan in
the 1880s
what edison gave us that system ran on
what's called direct current
and direct current you at the voltages
he was producing only goes about a mile
gretchen barkey is a cultural
anthropologist who writes about among
other things
the grit
he illuminated office buildings on wall
street for example mansions and then
small factory spaces
but every time you wanted to go more
than a mile you needed to build a new
power plant
and he thought this was fine he was like
this will be fine we'll just build
another one one mile over
and then another one and another one
and it was pretty clear that probably
direct current was not going to be the
long-term answer and so
that set up the next problem which was
how can we transmit electricity further
and the answer to that was given to us
by the famous nikola tesla who was quite
the guy
tesla came up with the idea of an
alternating current which
doesn't just flow in one direction it
keeps alternating back and forth on a
cable
alternating current it allows you to
increase the voltage to a very high
level whereas you couldn't do it with
direct current
bump up your current to higher voltage
and you can move your electricity a lot
further
there was some early rivalry over this
edison electrocuted an elephant to
demonstrate that ac was dangerous and
shouldn't be used
but ultimately ac was the clear winner
electricity was finally able to break
out of the one mile barrier
and that's why alternating current
became the dominant form of transporting
and using electricity world over
and that's the story of electricity just
kidding actually renewables ruined
everything
solar panels or even a wind farm
are not a corollary to a coal burning
power plant they're usually in different
places so coal we can bring it where we
want to burn it
wind we have to build where it's windy
and wind is often happening where
there's not that many people
currently we use alternating current to
be able to move electricity but the
problem with alternating current is that
if you move it over a very long distance
hundreds or even thousands of miles you
lose too much of that electricity
and so moving it long distances makes it
an uneconomical choice if we can't get
renewable energy where it needs to go we
can't transition away from fossil fuels
so we need a better way to move
electrons
[Music]
when we're talking about the history of
the grid the ac technology become the
dominant approach to distribute and to
transmit energy
nevertheless the dc technology did not
die
the opposite is actually the case
jorgen kosman is in charge of onshore dc
power systems at siemens energy
yes that's right dc power the loser of
the 19th century current wars is making
a comeback
the solution that has become a consensus
in the industry now is to use direct
current or more specifically high
voltage direct current
hvdc turns out to be the best of all
worlds traveling long distances without
losing as much power as ac along the way
dc wasn't able to go long distances
previously because you couldn't create a
high voltage version but inventions in
the past few decades have enabled us to
have the equipment and the power
electronics needed to generate high
voltage direct current
the engineers here make building size
machines that generate that sweet sweet
high voltage dc
they partner with companies like
italy-based prismian which make the
cables themselves long strands of
insulated copper or aluminium that can
span hundreds of miles
another important use case of the hvdc
technology is the interconnections of
countries to allow efficient energy
trading between the countries and the
network
the supergrid in a way is already a
reality in europe
denmark is connected to norway france is
connected to spain sweden is connected
to germany
interconnectors let countries take
advantage of renewable energy wherever
it's being generated if one country is
having a particularly windy day they can
share some of that power with their
neighbors
that's the idea behind the most recent
interconnector to be installed a project
called elect link that's routed through
the channel tunnel
[Music]
an interconnector allows surplus power
that isn't used in the uk
to be transmitted over to
to france
or alternately take some energy from
france and transmit it back to the uk
philippo gorman and his colleagues have
been working on elect link for more than
a decade and finally transmitted power
for the first time in may this year
we transmit up to a thousand megawatts
in either direction enough to power a
million to a million and a half homes
you're moving clean energy from a place
where it's in surplus to a place where
it's in demand
certainly throughout the world we're
going to be seeing a lot more
interconnectors you know across the
world across the globe
there is potential for them to do
exactly as we are doing now
but in other parts of the world this
idea has run into some trouble
when i was first beginning to research
the grid book which was in 2007
there was a thing in america called the
super grid
it didn't exist but anytime you talk to
anybody they would show you this
beautiful little map they'd be like
here's the map here's how we're going to
build these giant long distance high
voltage dc cables and
link the country
the problem is nobody would let anybody
build a long-distance power line like
you couldn't build a transmission line
in america
there is a surge of renewables being
built around the country and a lot of
the best renewable solar and wind
resources are in places like in the
central part of the country
but building transmission is really
difficult in this country
there is a patchwork of
federal state local landowner rights
that all have to be heard of communities
all have to have a say
so transwest is a planned transmission
line that would take about 3000
megawatts of wind power from wyoming
into vegas more than 700 miles and
transwest has been in development for 17
years
part of the reason it's taken that long
the project has had to secure permission
from more than 400 landowners along the
route and even a single holdout can
delay a project for years
ranch owner andy miniotis did ultimately
sell a chunk of his land to trans west
but he's not happy about it
drowns west they sent a young guy in
pretty pushy and
he'd get you flared up real quick with
his
pushing you they were going to condemn
you if you didn't agree with what they
wanted they're just going to take the
landing with nothing you're going to do
about it
i have no leverages like
i think they like to pick on the guys
they know that they've not got the money
to hire the lawyers to go to federal
court
if he waited and they actually filed
eminent domain papers then the value of
like what he could get out of that deal
would fall tremendously
i'm really not against you know the
power lines itself because i understand
that you know people need electricity
but it's the way they come in here and
now i'm going to be dealing with it with
construction
with people tearing the land up
i've already got a full plate to handle
with this ranch
just this year transwest settled with
the last holdout property owners meaning
that finally after 17 years construction
of the line can get started
and this is one of the more successful
examples in the us
[Music]
there are several transmission lines
that have been going through the process
it's been taking years
they're all held up for different
reasons
if we have this mandate to clean up the
grid by 2035 we're going to have to
figure out how to speed up the
construction of transmission
now to be able to build it in time
[Music]
meanwhile asia is trying to be less like
america and more like europe
obayashi runs japan's renewable energy
institute which has come up with a plan
to link up the grids of some of the
region's biggest economies
so the asia superglued is a concept to
integrate
asian countries
we started to focus on the eastern asian
countries like china and korea we focus
because that in far east asia there is a
mongolia which has the best renewable
energy potential in the area
that will benefit all asian countries
in theory wind and solar energy from
mongolia's gobi desert could produce as
much as 2.6 terawatts of electricity
more than twice the capacity of the
entire united states
the asia supergrid would link that power
to countries that produce more than a
third of the world's co2 emissions
it's an ambitious and potentially
transformative plan but it's not even
close to the biggest idea coming out of
asia
there is an idea that's being floated by
china to try and build a global grid
china has a state-owned company called
state grid that has the technology to
build hvdc lines
and has built many of them across china
and they want to try and promote this
idea of a globally interconnected
electric grid
it's hard to overstate the potential
climate impact of a global grid
connecting the most renewable rich parts
of the world to the most energy-hungry
population centers
but these proposals from asia are just
that proposals and that might not be
changing anytime soon
i have to say politics is the most
difficult thing
we are still trying to struggle each
other competing each other the japanese
government has tension with other
countries that especially that china
korea
countries that aren't 100
friendly aren't likely to want to link
their energy systems together
and with the war in ukraine making
european countries regret their
dependency on russian oil any notion of
a global super grid is likely to be off
the table for a good while but the way
mika sees it we're past the point where
the actions of individual countries can
move the needle on climate change
developed countries like japan you know
western world has to be
a renewable energy like a kind of a more
than 60 percent or 70 80 percent by 2030
so so we don't have enough time to do it
so i i'm always saying every single cent
or eve every single yen that we invest
something has to be invested for climate
change actions from now on
[Music]
as the grids evolved we have had to
cooperate on larger and larger scales
[Music]
edison's dc grids serve just a few
factories and rich people's homes the
grids of the 20th century spanned
nations and now the grids of the 21st
century would forge links between people
hundreds or even thousands of miles
apart
but if we can all get used to the idea
of being a little less isolated we might
find the puzzle of decarbonization gets
a lot easier to solve
which would be super
if we are going to hit net zero goals
and have 80 90 or 100 percent uh
renewable powered grids then
there is little chance to do that
without having really good transmission
across long distances
if we look to our targets and the
ambitions we have we need to accelerate
these processes and i think this is
doable
if we enable the grid to deal with this
new green energy generation i do believe
that a climate neutral world will be
possible
[Music]
you